je place au questionnaire le
questionnaire dix questions
traditionnelles
le questionnaire le questionnaire aux
drogues favorite quand même la vie mais
la vie la vie quoi la vie l'amour là
n'attire 22,8 l'humour le romanesque
l'eau chaude des salles de bains votre
drogue favorite dois le dire le daba le
tabac qu'elle as la cocaïne après un
gros pétard aux drogues favorite le
champagne les champagnes le vin le bon
vin votre drogue favorites ont le vin
rouge le son le bruit bourgogne le
bourgogne très bien mais ça vous allez
souvent tourné à dix journées qui la
ferait de la loire
le belge bel 79 je me pose beaucoup de
questions
favori de l'aspirer d'aspirine je crois
que c'est l'eau et ravenne outils et j'y
vais nulle tilleuls mais notre drogue
favorite
les sucres sont les chocolats le
chocolat au lait chocolat la mayonnaise
la stich pimentée
moi je pensais que vous allez me
répondre jésus votre drogue favorite le
travail le travail le travail le travail
votre drogue favori de le traîner un
boulet je n'avais pas l'intention de
message de détresse que c'est une drogue
achetée à six mois après le son le bruit
que leur dose de drogue favorite jean
d'ormesson la littérature l'écriture
était à la répétition sur une scène de
théâtre
votre droite favorite le théâtre blagues
favorites du cinéma - c'est le cinoche
sur leur lit le film de renoir ou de
john ford qu'elle vaut donc préféré
alors que les votes drogue préférée oui
je ne prends pas de drogue
mais en dépit de votre casquette pour
toi une fois décalé lui supporte donc à
skagway je pense que les 7000 en plus
c'est symbolique c'est quelque chose et
puis et puis
dans certains pays la le cannabis est
utilisé comme l'icann qui fume c'est ma
tête qui fut moine la grave
[Musique]